So President elect Joe Biden is starting to
fill out his cabinet.
And we learned just in the last few hours,
really, that Joe Biden, secretary of state,
is going to be Anthony Blinken.
And you are going to notice, as I tell you
about Anthony Blinken, that this is going
to be very, very different than Donald Trump's
approach.
Donald Trump's two secretaries of state were
an oil executive and a right wing nut, Congressman
Rex Tillerson and Mike Pompeo, respectively,
as secretaries of state.
Joe Biden is going to have a former deputy
secretary of state who started his career
at the State Department under the Clinton
administration has huge foreign policy experience
and quite frankly, is what you need temperamentally
when you want to sort of calm the panic of
our foreign allies.
After four years of a child in the White House
with their sycophants following them around
until they are no longer sycophants.
Rex Tillerson, of course, being an example
of that.
Now, this doesn't mean we're going to agree
with every cabinet pick that Joe Biden makes
on policy.
And we're going to talk about that in a little
bit.
But we are starting to actually select experienced
adults here, and that's a good sign.
We've also learned of two more choices for
Joe Biden.
They are Jake Sullivan for national security
adviser.
Sullivan was Joe Biden's national security
adviser as VP and also worked under Hillary
Clinton when she was secretary of state.
And then lastly, from what we know so far,
we heard about Ronald Klain a couple of weeks
ago, his chief of staff.
The last choice I have to tell you about today
is that Linda Thomas Greenfield is going to
be Joe Biden's ambassador to the United Nations.
Again, all important positions for rebuilding
relationships with allies.
She is a 35 year foreign service veteran.
And Biden, importantly, is going to put ambassador
to the U.N. back on the National Security
Council.
This might not seem huge.
This is one of those things that goes sort
of to the character of how a president approaches
international organizations like the U.N.
Part of Donald Trump's attacks on the United
Nations included downgrading the ambassador
to the U.N. so that they were no longer on
the NSC.
Joe Biden is going to put the ambassador to
the U.N. back on the National Security Council.
So a few thoughts so far on this.
I'm seeing posts going around about, for example,
oh, my God, Anthony Blinken is against BDS,
the movement to boycott Israel.
How dare Joe Biden?
Well, Joe Biden is against BDS.
Who would expect that Joe Biden would pick
a secretary of state in favor of BDS if they
themselves are against BDS?
That's kind of a strange reaction to have
now a Biden.
Blinken, rather, is Jewish and I hope that
oh my God, he's against BDS is not merely
code for oh my God, he's Jewish.
I'll give the benefit of the doubt on that.
Blinken did support the Iran deal.
There are going to be some in Israel who don't
like that.
I think the Iran deal was good.
Anthony Blinken supported the Iran deal.
I was in favor of the Iran deal, and I think
that that's a good thing.
Now, secondly, this now starts to give us
a sense of what the Biden foreign policy will
likely be with regard to foreign superpowers
as well as different regions of the world.
We're starting to see based on these selections
of Anthony Blinken as well as Jake Sullivan,
et cetera.
This probably means more time, effort and
resources are going to go into the relationship
with India as an example.
This probably means more time in Africa, where
China has spent significant time and resources
getting more involved with tech and infrastructure
over the last many years.
These are the type I mean, it feels weird
to even be talking with you guys in these
terms today because we're starting to get
back to policy.
We're starting to get back to geopolitics,
foreign policy, relationships between countries.
It's like this has been so sorely needed for
a long time.
Blinken likely will also have as a priority
to spend more time trying to bolster Guatemala,
Honduras, El Salvador and Latin America.
In what ways we don't yet know.
And then, of course, if it's Russia, China,
Africa and Latin America, what's missing from
that is Middle East.
And there may not be I mean, this may not
be an administration and a State Department
that is going to focus as much on the Middle
East as the recent three administrations have.
That doesn't necessarily that's not necessarily
a bad thing.
And of course, the devil is in the details.
Trump.
One interesting note is Donald Trump never
extended an arm controls deal with Russia,
and as a result of that, the incoming Biden
administration is going to have about two
weeks after inauguration to extend that with
Russia, if indeed it is going to be extended.
That's a big thing.
And that's going to set the tone for a lot
of the relaid the three way relationship between
the U.S., Russia and China.
And that's going to be in the first couple
of weeks of the Biden administration.
So that's something to look at.
Now, there's plenty of sort of good here,
a return to normalcy, adults at the table,
qualified people at the table.
What's the bad?
Anthony Blinken is no progressive.
That's that's the reality.
And Anthony Blinken is more interventionist
than I am, although Joe Biden has not shown
an interest during the campaign in campaigning
on interventionist priorities.
We know that Blinken is more of an interventionist
than Joe Biden ran on.
And this is something that I'm not on board
with generally.
As a rule of thumb, if you look at some of
Lincoln's past comments about Iraq seeming
to be more in the mindset of the problem was
how it was done rather than the fact that
it was done at all.
And that's something that I disagree with.
And this is the way that we are going to get
back into shifting to.
OK, great.
We've got adults back in charge.
This is a highly qualified choice and that's
a good thing.
But now we actually have to keep them accountable
about what they do now.
One one other thing.
There was a hilarious reaction from a lot
of people on the right about Biden's choosing
a known name.
Who the hell has ever heard of Anthony Blinken?
This is one of those things we're going to
have to become accustomed to after the Trump
administration.
Donald Trump regularly picked people because
he saw them on Fox News or saw them on TV.
It's OK to have people in positions of power
that are not regulars on cable news.
And that may not be household names.
That's fine.
And in fact, in some cases, it can be better.
And I think that it's a good thing that Joe
Biden is already going in that direction.